pero mientras 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida a la economía de brasil
creció en el tercer trimestre hola ron
muy buenas noches de lo hizo en un 7 7%
si se compara frente al segundo
trimestre sin embargo presenta una caída
del 39 por ciento frente al tercer
trimestre del año pasado lo que
evidencia la grave afectación que ha
tenido la pandemia sobre este país
aunque se puede ser un signo de
recuperación los analistas también están
preocupados por lo que pueda pasar en el
último trimestre esto debido a que el
gobierno suspendió los subsidios que
venía entregando entre los menos
favorecidos y ante la posibilidad de que
haya más restricciones en medio de una
nueva ola de kobe de 19 horas de las
preocupaciones de raúl son los altos
precios de la canasta familiar en
especial de los alimentos que lo han
obligado a importar y esto es muy
paradójico porque recordemos que brasil
es uno de los grandes productores
mundiales de comida
empleo hoy se hizo desde eeuu la más
grande importación de soja en 23 años y
esto se debe en parte a que brasil ha
hecho gigantescos envíos a china y ha
desabastecido su propio mercado
daniela y además los precios mundiales
de los alimentos subieron en el mes de
noviembre que acaba de terminar y
hablando de alimentos pues lo hicieron
en 3,9 por ciento y marcaron tres hitos
subieron por sexto mes consecutivo
alcanzaron su mayor nivel en seis años y
tuvieron su aumentos mensuales más alto
desde julio de 2012 así lo recoge el
informe mensual que publica la fao que
es la entidad de naciones unidas para la
alimentación y la agricultura de octubre
a noviembre los precios que más subieron
fueron los del aceite vegetal y tocaron
máximos desde marzo de 2014 porque hay
menos producción y más consumo le siguen
los del azúcar que aumentaron por
temores sobre un posible déficit de a
futuro por culpa del mal clima y los en
cereales por menos cosecha en argentina
eeuu y ucrania del otro lado pues
pero menos porque ninguno bajo son los
de los lácteos y las carnes aunque el
primero marcó un máximo de 18 meses
impulsado por la mantequilla y el queso
la carne aunque un aumento de este mes
en el año su precio ha caído casi un 14%
daniela y el congreso peruano aprobó
finalmente el retiro de los fondos
estatales de las pensiones cerrado
recordemos que en perú así como en
colombia y otros países funcionan dos
sistemas de pensiones el público y el
privado pues meses atrás se había
probado que quienes estuvieran en el
sistema privado pudieran hacer un retiro
anticipado del 25 por ciento de su
ahorro ahora el turno es de quienes
están afiliados al sistema público
alrededor de 18 millones de ciudadanos
que podrán retirar hasta mil 194 dólares
el gobierno rechazó la medida porque
este sistema funciona con un mecanismo
de reparto esto quiere decir raúl que la
mesada de los jubilados se paga con los
aportes de los trabajadores activos pero
mucho de ese dinero es financiado por el
estado porque hoy en día no alcanzan
esos aportes
lamentable situación alguien entonces
agricultores indios se rebelaron contra
el gobierno del primer ministro narendra
modi si lo hicieron con bloqueo de
algunas vías de la entrada a nueva delhi
este jueves se cumple una semana de las
protestas de miles de agricultores
contra la liberalización aprobada en
septiembre en el sector agrícola que
recordemos emplea a casi la mitad de los
1.300 millones de habitantes indios esta
reforma busca desde regular los precios
y la cantidad de productos vendidos es
decir los campesinos ya no tendrán un
precio garantizado y no van a vender
toda su cosecha en mercados mayoristas
regulados por el gobierno sino que ahora
podrán negociar los directamente con las
grandes empresas y para muchos esto
implicará pues que se aprovechen de
ellos las grandes multinacionales
daniela indicadores o estoy del cerro
mixto y esta vez el turno de batir el
récord o fue para el índice nasdaq
tecnológico signos dispares por su parte
también en las bolsas europeas con parís
y madrid a la baja
y en latinoamérica tercera subida
consecutiva para la bolsa de sao paulo y
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día 19 mil millones de dólares esto
pagará la aerolínea de bajo costo
europea ryanair en un histórico pedido
de 75 aviones boeing 737 más esta
referencia salió de nuevo al mercado
tras 20 meses paralizada por accidente
daniela como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información económica
ustedes también gracias continúen con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]